most people who've left mariopol have
had to make their own way out
pavel says he's used to the walking he's
a shepherd
we've got 35 kilometers to go he says
he and his wife jana are heading to
their village
away from the fighting they hope
around 140 000 people have escaped
mariopol in the five weeks since the
start of what russia calls its special
military operation
but not everyone made it to safety
those that do find themselves in
reception centers in russia or schools
like this in donetsk
why did we come here because it became
too hard we were exhausted i took julia
she hasn't been outside at all for a
month because she was scared very scared
and we went on foot a group in a column
until we reach the edge of the city and
the shooting and bombing but we made it
thank god
the people al jazeera spoke to say
they're here either because the only
route they could find out of mariopol
brought them this way or because they're
relatives in russia
of course i want to go home because i
have a flat there so i want to return to
my beloved city where i was born where
my daughter remains
and all my friends and relatives all my
life was spent in mariopol
ubov went on holiday to mariopol when
she was 18 years old
there she tells us
she fell in love
got married and has lived for 50 years
it was a perfect city she says
we must make peace with each other we
learn these words grads machine guns
women children why do they need to know
those words it is better to learn other
words those of peace love respect
towards each other but not machine guns
when your flat is on fire or the car
that's not real pain
the real pain is that we are being torn
apart
from the reception centers people will
go either to relatives in russia or
temporary accommodation that can be
hundreds of kilometers away
no one knows when they'll be able to go
back home to marry upon
and the red cross has asked the russian
government for permission to open an
office here in rostov-on-don to service
eastern ukraine we're about a 90-minute
drive from the border an indication
perhaps that this won't be a short-term
conflict
bernard smith al jazeera rostov-on-don